un petit clash avec rtl j'ai vu parce
que rtl il avait suggéré que vous vous
réconcilier avec eux j'ai refait leur
campagne de pub la lie clarisse et c'est
vrai que tu réponds à tout le monde pas
parce qu il utilise mon nom pour le buzz
mais derrière et passe pas ma musique
ouais c'est vraiment super sur rdl voyez
vous réveiller des gens là
sur rtl vous passionnés du bois parce
qu'elle est quand même moi je pensais
même moi je suis pas décisionnaire mais
tu penses que sur rtl - seaway away sur
rtl du booba way we sur moi n'a pas
commenté ce qui l'aurait fait depuis 27
ans
si on vote sept ans ils sont pas rêver
mais j'ai évolué comme en plus vous là
vous avez dit que vous viendriez si non
mais ils passent pas de rap sur rmc
ça s'ils passent pas d'europe qui parle
pas de moi
parce qu'ils sont facilement ils ont
passé pénibilité dernier
opportunistes se comprend bah oui mais
c'est un peu beaucoup sauf que de la
part de rmc moyen en fait je vois là ils
l'ont fait ils l'ont fait
on ne demande pas l'autorisation quand
ils l'ont fait avec tout le monde adore
merkel il aime beaucoup bon bah c'est
vrai il paraît énorme série qui l'adoré
oui il s'était alors tellement qui me
joue pas alors je ne suis pas dans le
secret des dieux mais je sais que c'est
à l'étude mais la preuve la mise à
l'étude
si
tu
dois faire sur un album numéro 1 est une
radio tu me passes mais attend et je
n'ai pas essayé de passer du cartel
comme un adieu booba demain sur la scène
sans rigoler je te dire comment serait
pas renégociée n'augmenteront allait
super
c'est comme ça alors je voudrais
d'ailleurs félicité isabelle car ce
matin 1 isabelle était sur rtl mais non
merci et isabelle sa fin un exploit mais
je vais demander à tout public de se
lever dans un instant non parce que
lundi nous étions avec mon ami booba et
la question s'est posée de savoir si rtl
pouvez diffuser un son de booba
évidemment isabelle en celi depuis le
baptême de clovis
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
a défendu son employeur rtl et elle a
dit je mettrais du booba maintenant
est-ce que rtl la deuxième radio de
france
a changé son fusil d'épaulé en diffusant
du booba grâce à isabelle
impossible regardez et peut-être que
dans un instant il y aura ce qu'on
appelle une standing ovation à venir des
applaudissements debout regarde
j'ignore si vous le savez yves mais le
rappeur booba quelle belle tête pense
que rtl ne diffusera jamais sa musique
sur l'antenne mais pourquoi pourquoi où
ça si c'est possible or donc la preuve
immédiatement avec cet extrait du titre
dragon
en cause
[Musique]
c'est pas compétents dont sa cession par
ge c'est l'une des plus belles têtes que
j'ai vu j'ai le croque revient avec un
triangle
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
lots de l'opération trois décès ce matin
[Rires]
malheureusement quittés on les embrasse
bien fort non mais c'est vrai et julien
courbet a passé le titre en intégralité
en rappelant le contexte fm pas regarder
bond à l'extrême nord
alors baba encore mieux on joue les
rasoir à deux lames moi j'ai passé un
extrait du titre dragon empreinte thème
de la radio à 9h30 juste avant julien
compères mais justement julien lui il va
diffuser le titre en intégralité alors
promesse tenue est retenu car propos de
retenir puisque nous on a piraté leur
tête maintenant laval dans ton corps à
jouer booba nous dit bah oui mais vous
utilisez mon image sur les affiches
alors qu'on ne passe pas mais disent que
sur rtl mais simon booba on les passait
c'est une grande première pour la
première fois booba sur rtl le voici
[Applaudissements]
wayne is a web à présent
ouais mais ça
et je tiens à remercier les grands
patrons d'rtl miami que j'aime régis
ravanas exceptionnel